[Music]
[Applause]
he is a professor of biology at the
University of Virginia his name is
Ignacio provincio or you can call him
Iggy and we wanted to have him on
because he would like the United States
to switch to permanent Standard Time not
daylight savings time and the professor
joins us now on the program how did you
get involved in this Iggy
well I've had an interest in this for a
long time since I was a graduate student
and I've been interested in circadian
rhythms so we have this internal 24-hour
clock that dictates when we sleep when
we're awake and
um so this long-standing interest has
been something that I've pursued for
over 35 years now take us back to when
it started
and because it feels like there were I
think I grew up thinking it was for
farmers and realized that it was about
World War one and World War II
yeah that's correct actually in World
War One
um daylight savings time was implemented
for the first time in order to conserve
coal so it was really an energy uh
saving
um thing and then it was discontinued
and then in World War II it was then
enacted again at the time it was called
wartime
um and then it wasn't until uh and then
after that all the jurisdictions had the
Liberty to either have daylight savings
time or not so you can imagine the
confusion that that caused and finally
in 1966 it was made permanent by
Congress through the uniform time Act
well on Tuesday didn't the U.S Senate
passed the bill to make Daylight Savings
Time year round
in fact yeah okay and and now goes to
the House of Representatives
right and last year uh the sunshine
protection act was put forth and
actually passed in the Senate by Senator
Rubio in Florida
um but it was stopped in the house last
year and uh my hope is
um that uh it will be stopped in the
house this year because
permanent daylight savings time is the
um greater of two evils and that that
being well actually the second evil
would be
the current situation that we're in now
where we switch twice a year the best
situation would be to be on permanent
Standard Time
give me uh some of the positives of what
we have now if there are any in your
opinion
um I think emotionally I personally like
having you know more light later into
the night but it's completely unnatural
so I think that the advantages are
really minor compared to the
disadvantages there's some real Health
consequences to the current situation so
actually the consequences are basically
twofold the first is that when we
actually move the clocks the day after
we move the clocks there's a higher
incidence of heart attacks
um the spring shift alone has been
blamed for an additional 28 traffic
fatalities every year
so the actual times when we move the
clocks are actually quite dangerous and
then in addition to that um they're the
long terms effect of having a shifted
clock being out of synchrony with the
natural light dark cycle
so um this really all started with the
Advent of the light bulb the light bulb
has allowed us to be working and we
should be asleep
uh and uh our mid-sleep should actually
coincide with astronomical mid midnight
right so the middle of the night should
be the middle of our sleep are you
anti-light bulb Professor is that what
you're saying you're anti-elightful
yeah that's me no no I I understand the
benefits of the light bulb don't get me
wrong but it has actually
um screwed up our natural Timing System
okay so uh how does this end how do you
think uh the House of Representatives
votes on this
um I I don't know I'm a biologist I'm
not a political scientist but uh My Hope
Is that they will not vote for permanent
daylight saving time
um but we'll see we'll see
is there an ideal nap time during the
day
um and length of nap
yeah
I think you're you're best off not
napping and just you know sleeping a
significant number of hours during the
night
so I would argue that there's not an
ideal nap time that you just shouldn't
nap
um but um if you know if you are sleep
deprived then um yeah you probably
should nap at some point I'm not sure
there's an ideal nap time per se
and it's still eight hours
that's eight hours is optimal I mean our
ancestors actually slept longer and in
fact we slept longer during the winter
when the nights were longer and we slept
shorter during the summer when the
nights were shorter
um but if you could get eight hours
you're probably
um doing pretty well you know the
consequences of being out of sync with
your environment or you know quite
severe there's an increased risk of
cancer there's an increased risk of
cardiovascular disease there's an
increased risk of metabolic disorders
such as diabetes and even for athletic
performance
um an old study showed that West Coast
teams traveling to the east coast we're
at a 1.24 run disadvantage by having to
travel all those time zones we have one
of our guys here Paulie is saying in two
years we will not have this it'll be
gone
what do you think
daylight saving time will be gone yeah
um could be I mean there was a recent
poll by Monmouth uh you know this poll
showed that uh 44 of the respondents
actually were in favor
of permanent daylight savings time uh
only 13 percent wanted it to be
permanent um Standard time which I think
is the correct way of proceeding and
about 35 percent wanted the current
system that we have so it is popular I'm
not going to deny that but um just from
a biological standpoint it's not the the
best of the options good to talk to you
Professor keep fighting the good fight
thank you very much that's Professor
Ignacio provencio biology Professor
University of Virginia you can call
immigy